ela sobe 20 e hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma faca do papel mais conhecido
pelo nome de bater flec na ifa em inglês
como vocês podem ver que eu sou um
grande armador misto é mas dá impressão
que eu sou bom porque eu já fui muito
rápido aqui pra começar tem que rolar
uma folha fazer um tubinho s.paulo o
tubinho e prendem com fita de um lado a
outro
agora a parte a ponta com vocês como
vocês acharem fica melhor e fiz jacques
vocês gostarem podem fazer igual
depois de fazer com vocês quiserem tem
que fechar as partes onde vocês cortaram
podem usar para isso fita cola ou então
cola pediu que eu fiz aqui mas marcações
afirmado em cortar mais ou menos como o
dinheiro que aí aquelas faixas ficam
literalmente em mais ou menos 0,5
centímetro do brasil daquele modo aquela
parte central e vou cortar deixando uma
pequena alta de 3,5 centímetros e 3
sente
veja como é que vai ficar assim por
dentro para ficar mais bonita e eu fiz
assim um retão de cada lado e vou
aprender aqui com fita estas camadas
para ficar mais resistente
se vocês quiserem podem usar cola aqui
também
e como é óbvio tem que fazer no outro
lado da mesma maneira por ficar
simétrico e com a mesma resistência
e também tem que forçar esta parte
agora tem que rolar uma folha com se
fosse uma gripe que ela das férias
caso você não consiga fazer isso direito
vou deixar um link de inscrição quando
se fazer isso mais brigar para passar
fazendo e vai ter que fazer um pne foi a
volta e tem que prender com fita para
não ser lá já que a marcação quem é da
largura daquela faixa branca
duas faixas brancas na lâmina executar
um tubinho para cada faixa branca para
explicar mais resistente tem que levar
uma cola super cola e pôr no lugar onde
estou e vou estar aqui depois de tentar
ficar 30 covas cara é você tem por esta
partida assim
deste modo um ponto cola aos poucos
hotéis não tenta impor de uma vez
veja aqui como ficou a mina e passar uma
resistência e vou juntar aqui três fãs
com fita e carreta ou não estas rifas
vão aumentar bastante a existência desta
a já que estou a fazer as marcações para
cortar e é parte da resistência entrar
lá dentro sem nada ficará fora daqui e
vou introduzir dentro da escola nessa
parte em ambos os lotes e agora fazer a
parte da guerra da faca que mais algumas
roupas
vocês vão ver com seguida fiz aqui outro
lá para cá porque é muito idêntica
inicial é seguramente mais pequena e
cola é desta maneira que vocês poderiam
usar fita aqui pra juntar as duas partes
só que não vai ficar tão resistente até
então eu constato que vocês usem cola
para finalizar a encurtar dois tubinhos
e claro a esta parte aqui um e depois no
outro lado em quase pronto já está perto
do estado
se vocês quiserem ajudar o canal da
mancha com vai que se inscrevam caso não
sejam de crítica é essencial a cedeao